I think what my grandfather was saying
the message of his speech was that all
people men and women and children should
be treated equally with dignity and
respect it doesn't matter the color of
your skin it doesn't matter your
religion it doesn't matter what country
you're from or the languages that you
speak that everyone should be treated
equally I don't think it's as relevant
as it might have been back then but I
think it is still a really important
part of our life because sometimes as
people we need reminders and still with
those insights going on now we need this
reminder I think the American Dream
speech is relevant today because we
still have not created this Beloved
communities this community this society
this nation that is inclusive and that
respects the dignity Worth and value of
all people we're still living in a time
where people are looked upon in a very
negative light they're treated in fact
in very inhumane ways and I think my
father is speaking to us that that is
your brother that is your sister
regardless of our differences regardless
of our ideologies what unites us is that
notion of together we win that we are
interconnected that we are interrelated
and that I cannot exist without you and
you cannot exist without me and so I
think the speech is is relevant more
importantly today because there's so
many people who feel alike only their
particular group matters and that's not
true we all matter we're all a part of
the American dream and we're part of
that dream more importantly that my
father spoke about in 63 and in the
essence we are all a part of the Beloved
Community we just have to learn as he
said how to live together as
and sisters so that we are not forced to
perish its fools one has to understand
it was delivered at a time when America
was sort of just coming out of elements
of segregation because this was 1965 and
while we had been an integrated society
Society for a while there still was a
lot of segregation that existed and
separation so from a contextual
standpoint what I believe my father was
saying is that America in its founding
documentation documents essentially
talked about the dignity and Worth and
freedom of all human beings so it was
not just written as a document for one
ethnic group it was written for everyone
and and also everyone had the ability to
achieve his or her own dream of if he or
she was treated with dignity and respect
I think the speech is absolutely
relevant today as we are going through a
lot of division within our nation and
really divisions I should say in our
worlds we are attempting to be
segregated and separated and dad told us
how to disagree without being
disagreeable and I think that's
something we need to learn not just in
the political discourse but in the whole
discourse of our nation we will not be
able to achieve greatness if we are at
each other's necks as we are today